so we've talked about push and pull
queues now but what if you just want to
do something at regular intervals for
example perform a backup remove
temporary files or send a daily report
that midnight every day that's exactly
what a cron job does it's a scheduler an
app engine cron job is very similar to a
cron job in UNIX if you have worked with
that so cron is a scheduler within app
engine that allows you to specify asks
that are executed regularly cron is
perfect to use to perform background
tasks which are not directly initiated
from user activity for example to run
batch or synchronization jobs of
different kinds and backups etc the cron
job is very easy to configure and there
are two things you need to specify first
of all the URL that should be called
this is where you place the code you
want to execute and then you also need
to specify the schedule which controls
when the task URL is called and as with
queues there is a 10-minute limit for
dynamic instances if you want more time
than that you can use resident instances